y'all will post things like this
and genuinely not see a single issue with this fact
you can buy 3 shirts 3 shirt for less than a price of a burger
does that not ring like a single alarm bell in your brain
are there like any thoughts further than oh I can get more
I can consume more
you have no thoughts that are like oh I wonder how can this shirt be that cheap
what's going on behind the scenes that will make these three shirts
cheaper than a burger
I'm not even one of those people that demonizes fast fashion
because I think it's a very complex issue
and I do know that at least for plus size people
fast fashion is often the only option that we have
but like we need to work on a relationship to clothing
cause the way that fast fashion has genuinely changed
the way that we think about clothes
the average consumer
fast fashion does not comprehend how much clothing is actually worth
because every time you buy these items of clothing
for like less than $5
it almost always means that somewhere along line
there are people being exploited to make that garment for you
I know this will get people to change their opinion overnight
but like think about your relationship to consumption into clothing
and understand the consequences of you being able to buy a three dollar shirt